[Music]
it takes a long time to make a human we
can sometimes I think it caught up in
our own perceptions of how life works
but there are some organisms that don't
have the luxury of years and years of
childhood no for them life is brief and
they've got to get on with living and so
sometimes like with the gastro trick
they'll just go ahead and have their
first baby on the day they're born now
we've never had the chance to name a
species of microbe we name individuals
all the time this one's an eel but
naming a species seems like both a
thrilling and weighty task you take this
strange new tiny thing and you assign it
an identity that it will never know but
that other human observers will come to
rely on ostensibly forever and through
the years people who have faced this
challenge have turned to a wealth of
imagery and language to guide them
there's the multi headed serpent of
Greek and Roman mythology now also the
name for the multicellular regenerating
wonder of hydras or you could go cuter
like the tardigrade which translates
roughly to slow stepper which also has
the advantage of being accurate and then
you have gastric tricks
also known by their phylum name gastro
trikha these organisms were not named in
so flattering a fashion no gastro trikha
translates to hairy stomachs and when
you don't feel like saying gastro trick
you can also call them by their common
name hairy backs but a rose is a rose by
any other name and truth is they do have
hairy stomachs and backs all as we will
see for good reason but if their name
doesn't capture the mythological glory
that other organisms get there are
moments when the light hits just right
and bounces off their little scales that
gastric tricks resemble iterations of
one of the most pervasive mythological
figures of all time
the dragon we should scale back a bit
though
after all gastro tricks are among some
of the smallest metazoans or we could
say less esoterically animals they range
from around 60 to 500 micrometers long
though in some very exceptional cases
they might get up to several millimeters
in length there are two orders in the
gastro trick a phylum chitin odda which
are mostly found in freshwater and macro
dis EDA which are found in marine
systems though there are weirdly a few
freshwater species no matter what order
they belong to they make up part of
what's called the Maya fauna these are
species grouped by their size too big to
be microfauna too small to be macro
fauna the Maya faunal organisms are
between 60 micrometers to 2 millimeters
and they play a deeply important
ecological role a bridge between the
micro and the macro consuming the former
and being consumed by the latter they
are a part of this system that brings
nutrients out from the microscopic world
into the parts of ecosystems that we can
directly
observe castro tricks are among the most
abundant species present in the Maya
fauna in some habitats it's been
estimated that there are around 100,000
individual gastro tricks per square
meter and there are around 860 known
species counted across both orders now
that's a lot of species of gastro tricks
but it's actually surprisingly low
compared to the diversity of other Maya
faunal organisms there are for example
over 2000 rotifer species and
approximately 40,000 species of nematode
now this doesn't mean anything bad for
gastro tricks though it might be why
they have yet to be found in any extreme
kind of habitat but it is remarkable
that for microscopic metazoans 860
species is low when you put it up
against some other phyla returning to
their unfortunate but well-earned name
the stomach's of gastro tricks are
covered in hair like cilia which they
use to glide along surfaces as they dine
on bacteria algae and other small
particles unfortunately for us it is
hard to observe and film these hairy
stomachs because well they swim with
their bellies down we found that when we
record gastro tricks we have to be extra
careful their head is covered in cilia
and mechanoreceptors that seem to
respond to any slight movement in the
water so it's important not to create
any accidental vibrations a microscope
that might startle them gastric bodies
are enclosed in a cuticle and covered in
spines or scales or sometimes both and
at the end of their bodies many species
have a pair of feet which hold adhesive
tubes that they can use to attach to
grains of sand or other objects and
underneath the hairy scaly cuticle we
see the wonder
of a multicellular body a brain nervous
system simple gut intestines muscles and
more inside of this Chet Annette gastric
is an egg and when that egg hatches out
will come a new gastro trick Forgan in
place and about 2/3 the length of a full
adult the fact that it hatches
so formed is remarkable on its own but
the whole reproductive cycle of Chet
nits is a marvel gastro tricks are not
particularly long living creatures their
lifespan is on the order of days two
weeks which means they have to cram a
lot of living into a short amount of
time when they hatch
Chetta needs seem to immediately begin
developing their eggs through
parthenogenesis a kind of cloning
through which an unfertilized egg is
able to develop into an embryo that is
genetically the same as the parent in
the species and conditions that
Chettinad reproduction has been most
extensively documented in you might see
a gastro trick lay an egg within a day
after they themselves hatch and
typically they'll lay four eggs within
four days that can develop and hatch
within a day of being laid producing
genetically identical offspring and
those children are then out there
themselves laying eggs meaning a gastro
trick can become a grandmother just a
few days after it was born and here's
another weird thing sometimes they lay a
special kind of egg called an OPS a
plastic egg which has spines and is
thicker and larger compared to the other
eggs qualities that keep it protected
under harsher conditions because of this
rapid egg laying we used to think that
chetan its were entirely made up of
partha genetic females but later
observations have revealed that once
these early eggs get
the Chetta needs become hermaphroditic
developing sperm and eggs what they used
the sperm for though is a mystery we
just don't have the observations we need
to understand how Chetan ins make use of
their hermaphroditic phase this life
history though characterizes just the
Chetan its macro - Hoyt gastro tricks
seemed to be all hermaphroditic except
for one species and so their process is
of course different and yet the result
is the same the direct development of
young gastro tricks that contain the
full multicellular plan in their own
body ready to create the next generation
at birth it's hard to know sometimes
what to be most impressed by when you're
looking into the micro cosmos is it the
giant unicellular organism or the tiny
multicellular one is it giving birth on
the day you were born or the 40,000
species of nematodes of course chances
are just minutes ago you had no idea
that the earth was covered in these tiny
beasts bridging the worlds of the micro
and the macro and now we can't even
decide what the coolest thing about them
is complexity is its own complex thing
so carry on our hairy bellied friend and
thank you for coming on this journey
with us as we explore the unseen world
that surrounds us and thank you
especially to all of the people on the
screen right now who support us via
patreon these people allow us to
continue diving into these mysteries
it's a joy to do and we're so happy that
you are compelled to help us out if you
want to see more from our master of
microscopes James you can check them out
on Jam and germs and if you want to see
more from us here at journey to the
micro cosmos you could find us on
twitter at twitter.com/zeromd
youtube.com
slash micro cosmos
[Music]